this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
[Music]
every night during the holy month of
ramadan muslims around the world attend
an iftar a meal to break the day's
religious fast
but in iran's holy city of mashad there
is an iftar like no other india was
exciting
has
[Music]
during the 30 days of ramadan the imam
reza mosque hosts a breakfast of epic
proportions
every night as the sun sets thousands of
meals are served to hungry observers
he joined
cooking for that many people can be a
daunting job so they enlist the help of
over 400 volunteers
mission
to pull this off the volunteer chefs
start their day at 5am and spend most of
their time chopping and stirring the
evening's meal
but 13 000 meals means a lot of food
the mosque goes through two tons of
fresh vegetables four tons of rice and
three tons of meat every single night
[Music]
[Music]
but despite the challenges volunteers
and patrons alike consider
[Music]
on
[Music]
you